so why do Elon Musk Ray do and multiple
fourstar generals say China's going to
be invading Taiwan in no time but if you
look at the numbers it all makes sense
why they will or more importantly need
to because they actually need what
Taiwan has to offer so anyways let's set
that part aside when you think about us
and import export you think about Panama
Canal when you think about what's
important to Europe you think about sus
Canal but when you think about China
Philippines Malaysia India you would
think about the straight of Mala so the
reason why this is important to China is
because just a few years ago every day
China with ships would come and move and
dump 3 and 12 acres of sand every day
just to build land so they can say their
Island which turned into the N Dash line
to protect them to say that is our
territory because that entire area is
filled with many US allies so God forbid
if they all unified against China China
would be in a lot of trouble why here's
some data for you $5.3 trillion trade is
passing through the South China see
every year more than 60% of global
Maritime trade and more than 22% of
total global trade passes through this
water body onethird of the global
Shipping passes through the sea every
year over 60% of its tradeit in value
traveling by sea more than half of the
world's fishing vessels are in the South
China Sea and the same exact region is
also thought to contain oil reserve of
at least 7.7 billion barrels some even
say 213 billion barrels if that is true
that would be the equivalent of about
80% of the oil reserves of Saudi Arabia
and last but not least one Chinese
estimat that the entire South China Sea
estimates natural gas reserves to be two
quadrillion cubic feet quadrillion is
one more than a trillion so when you
look at that China looks at this entire
area says guys we got to figure
something out here we cannot give this
thing up we need all of this stuff for
many different reasons this is why many
believe that China will eventually
invade Taiwan we're going to talk about
that today
okay so if you give Al out of this video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel so let's get right into it so
look this entire area the South China
Sea who cleanses territory China is
trying to say this is our territory and
why they started building all these
islands which which we'll take a look at
it but let's first learn about what this
nine dash line really mean so this
refers to a demarcation line used by the
People's Republic of China and Taiwan to
claim large portions of the South China
Sea the line encompasses about 90% of
the South China Sea and includes areas
claimed by several other countries so
what are the origins of this this
concept for the first line appeared on a
Chinese map in 1947 initially it had 11
dashes but by 1949 when the Communists
took over mainland China and established
a People's Republic of China the claim
was inherited by the PRC while the
Republic of China retreated to Taiwan
and in 1950s the two dashes in the Gulf
of tonken were removed thus leading to
the nine dash line the significance of
this is that the South China see is rich
in resources such as oil natural gas
Fisheries additionally it's one of the
world's major shipping routes making its
control significant both economically
and strategically you ever wonder why
Jamie Diamond CEO of Chase has a $900
million art collection or Steve Cohen
$1.1 billion art collection or Microsoft
has nearly a billion doll collection the
company f ,000 art pieces in 180
different locations worldwide why
because billionaires and millionaires
understand one of the ways to hedge
against inflation money being printed
market crash interest rates is to buy
non duplicatable assets and one of them
is Art Fine Arts and that's why today's
sponsor is Masterworks let me tell you a
little bit about Masterworks you may be
watching the Say pat I'm not a
millionaire or a billionaire I can't
afford to buy a warhall or A banks your
basat how am I going to buy that well
Masterworks allows you to buy fractional
shares like buying a share of Apple you
buy a share of a bank seit painting or a
Warhol piece you're able to do that
through Masterworks this is why over
800,000 people have signed up with
Masterworks offerings have sold out
within minutes and many of you have
already created accounts and some of you
that haven't this is your chance to skip
the waiting list and start your
collection today just click on the link
in the description go to
masterworks.io and once again
Masterworks for/ Val or click on a link
below now when it comes on to the
territorial claims with the n-h line
there are several archipelago namely the
parcel Islands the spratley islands and
the scar bro sha these land features are
also claimed holy or in part by several
countries in the region including the
Philippines Vietnam Malaysia brune and
Taiwan look you may be saying this Pat
who cares about these two dash line the
N Dash line the 11 dash line this is so
sensitive to people who live in this
area to the point where Vietnam banned
the movie Barbie from being played in
Vietnam because of the way it drew the
n- line they were offended by it's it's
a very sensitive topic in that area so
now international disputes China's
extensive claims based on the n- line
have resulted in multiple territorial
disputes in the South China area these
tensions have occasionally escalated
into standoffs and confrontations and
the en Clause text the United Nations
convention on the law of the sea is an
international treaty that defines
nation's rights and responsibilities in
the world's oceans that establishes
guidelines for businesses the
environment and the management of marine
natural resources however the n- line
claim does doesn't adhere to the
conventional territorial sea limits set
by un Clos China is a signatory of un
Claus but interprets it in ways that
supports its broad claims in the South
China Sea let's talk about the 2016
ruling in 2013 the Philippines initiated
a case at the permanent Court
arbitration PCA against China
challenging the validity of the n-h line
and in 2016 the PCA ruled in favor the
Philippines on several key issues
notably it included that China's n- line
claim has no no legal basis under un
Claus however China rejected the ruling
and it did not lead to significant
changes on the ground China continues to
assert its claims in the South China Sea
often back in its stance with Naval and
Coast Guard patrols as well as land
reclamation and militarization of
certain features this has resulted in
tensions not only with neighboring
countries but also with extra Regional
Powers most notably the United States
which conducts freedom of navigation
operations in that area so according to
the exclusive economic zone there's a
number of how many miles a land can be
from a country to say that's ours so
when you look at e according to
international law an exclusive economic
zone or E is an area of the ocean
generally extending 200 nautical miles
roughly 230 Mi Beyond a nation's
territorial sea within which a coastal
nation has jurisdiction over both living
and non-living resources so if you look
at China and Taiwan you know what the
distance is 81 mies so this is where
China is trying to say Taiwan is part of
us and Taiwan saying no no no we're our
own country we have nothing to do with
you so it's such a cluster in South
China Sea that all these countries are
building fake Islands man-made Islands
to say whoa this is within 200 miles and
this is our territory and everyone said
no that's not your territory China's
doing it Malaysia's doing it Vietnam's
doing it Philippines doing it literally
everybody in that territory is doing it
led by the quam minang party the kmt
party resumed at civil war with the
Chinese Communist party and by 1949 the
CCP emerged Victorious on the mainland
leading on the establishment of the
People's Republic of China the kmt led
by Chiang Kai Sheek retreated to Taiwan
along with about 2 million refugees and
the kmt continued to declare itself the
legitimate government of all of China
and vowed to retake the mainland and
that leads us to the separate paths from
1950 onwards Taiwan underwent
significant Economic Development
transforming from an agrarian society to
one of the four Asian tigers initially
an authoritarian State under martial law
Taiwan also began a process
democratization in the late 80s
culminating its first presidential
election in 1996 in other words Taiwan
sees themselves as their own country
guys leave us alone let us know what
we're doing here we got our own economy
we're doing good so now how is US
handling this relationship with China
and Taiwan up until 1979 the US
officially recognized the Republic of
China on Taiwan as the legitimate
government of all China however in a
move to establish former relations with
the People's Republic of China and
Beijing the US switched diplomatic
recognition from taipe to Beijing on
January 1st of 19 79 the PRC views
Taiwan as part of its territory and one
of its conditions for diplomatic
relations was that the US could not
maintain official diplomatic ties with
both the PRC and the Roc and that led to
the Taiwan Relations Act while the US
severed formal diplomatic ties with
Taiwan in 1979 it passed the Taiwan
relations act the same year the TR
provides a legal framework for the
continuation of unofficial relations
between the US and Taiwan it also
commits the US to provide Taiwan with
arms of defensive care character and
states that any effort to undermine
taiwan's future by nonp peaceful means
would be of great concern to the US and
by the way they're saying this trying to
make two people happy look this is your
business you guys kind of figur it out
but we got a great relationship with
them and we got a great relationship
with you and we don't want to see you
bully these guys if you do we can't do
business with you so us is kind of
holding this conflict from taking place
because China knows if they do something
here they may lose the US relationship
and they desperately still need the US
relationship so it's important to know
which country needs this area the most
not just based on their GDP but as well
as the percentage of all the trade they
do so look at this here us if you look
at this look at the top it says country
then percentage of share of world GDP
then it says trade value through South
China Sea in billions then it's at South
China SE trade as percentage of all
trade in Goods us it's only 5.72% but
look at China
39.5% then it's Japan it's 19% Germany 9
UK it's 12% France 7 or 8% India's 31%
Italy's 8 Brazil's 23 Canada's 2 or 3%
but if you look at China nearly
40% there's one country that cannot
afford a lot of conflict in this area
and that's China America can CU it's
only 5.72 but China first then India it
matters to the both of them so so to
just kind of help give a visual so you
understand what this means let's just
say China all of a sudden had conflicts
with all of these guys none of them want
to work with them not Vietnam not
Philippines not Malaysia and us and
they've made us upset if you look look
at this chart where do they go through
to get the shipments of everything they
need do they go all the way around can
they no longer use the malaka straight
or the Sunda straight or the lumo
straight they're going to need all of
that diplomacy matters more to China
than any other country in that region so
now you may say well Pat you still
haven't answered the question about
Taiwan why do they need Taiwan let me
explain a little bit more number one if
you watched our semiconductor video you
would know why they need it cuz Taiwan
produces some of the most highly
demanded technical difficult
semiconductor chips in the world they
need need taiwwan but it's more than
just semiconductor chips they're worried
about the trade vulnerability China is
landlocked and heavily dependent on
Imports over North Desert the West
Himalayas and South which is a jungle
60% of its trade is value traveling by
sea and between 20 and 2020 China's food
self-sufficiency ratio decreased from
93.6% to
65.8% and last but not least China
Imports over 70% of its oil so again
they need that area and if you look at
this here with us Naval bases and
installations look how focused we are
here whether it's Naval Air facility
whether it's US Naval Base whether it's
Naval Station area whether it's contract
granted Naval base or whether it's
enhanced defense cooperation agreement
provides US forces with rotational
access to these bases America is there
and that doesn't make China comfortable
but it makes their alliances comfortable
something China probably doesn't like
now some people ask and say well Pat how
strong is Taiwan against China take a
look at this chart here this is
according to Statia the military
imbalance in the Taiwan straight if you
look at mainland China is the red and
Taiwan is the blue so Personnel
obviously they got a lot more but Taiwan
would offer an additional 89 tanks
Taiwan would offer another 850 if
they're able to invade them artillery
pieces you see the numbers there
aircraft carriers they have nothing to
offer destroyers they have four to offer
frates they got 22 to offer tank Landing
ships they got 31 to offer submarines
only two fighters they got 300 bomber
attack zero Transport Aircraft look at
that right there 30 to 20 so now if you
say but patat we I'm still anoid like
what Dalo musk and fourstar general
saying they're still going to invade him
no problem the challenge China's going
to face is there's only two months out
of the year that they can attack them
because the sea in that area is very
choppy so the only two months they have
it's not like it's a backto back two
months or it's like 60 days straight
it's either April or it's October any
other month it's tough for them to
invade the other problem they have is
they don't have any allies everybody
surrounding that area just doesn't like
China whether it's Japan South Korea
Taiwan their allies of us or it's
Philippines Indonesia Vietnam and India
again they're they're not full-on allies
of what China's got going on and then
the way Taiwan is set up as a country
the region it's a little bit out of
whack if you look at this chart right
here if you look at the green the green
will show you that there's roughly 3700
m in elevation is the green and then the
rest is a little bit lower which means
if somebody wants to invade it's not
really the most ideal way an island is
set up to invade but again they could if
they want to but it's going to be a
little bit more challenging and for
Taiwan to fight a potential Invasion
they've got some certain things they've
done themselves as well which one is
mine Lane ships in case they do attack
boom they would explode setting up oil
pipelines at Beach entry points that can
dump oil into the ocean and set the
entry point on fire they've scorched
Earth tactics Guerilla Warfare and China
does not have the infrastructure to
deploy its entire air fleet into the
combat zone so China's Navy has quantity
but it lacks quality and most of China's
military jets cannot make it to Taiwan
because of its distance so now the the
case study that China has China's been
watching Russia invade Ukraine to see
well let's see how the world is reacting
to it at least Ukraine there is part of
NATO so NATO's going to back up Ukraine
but who's Taiwan part of well maybe this
is the reason why China could attack
Taiwan but if they do Taiwan has a lot
of allies and does China want to lose us
what if they lose us and okay let's just
say China does invate Taiwan who's going
to back him up an emptied Russia with
resources that's who's going to back him
up who's going to back him up so it's
very complicated when you look at this
China's friend making skill set is not
that good they've not made enough
friends in that region in that area to
say we're willing to help you they've
pissed everybody off that uh is not
wanting to see this become a reality so
MOS Rayo fourstar generals very smart
for saying that this could possibly
happen and it could possibly happen but
if it does it may be very complicated on
the way they do it they're definitely
going to need someone's help whose help
no one knows yet having said that if you
got value out of this video give it a
thumbs up subscribe to the channel if
you've not seen our video on NATO
exposed it's a phenomenal video click
here watch that video take care
everybody bye- bye bye-bye
[Music]